have you ever been betrayed most of us
have
maybe you've had a best friend run away
with your girl or had a co-worker steal
an idea that you wanted to pitch to your
boss
or maybe your partner knocked on you to
the feds
you're an fbi informant
are you kidding me
being betrayed is pure anguish
you packers fans you guys know what i
mean remember how it felt seeing brett
favre and the purple and gold of the
vikings after all those years in green
bay you couldn't believe your guy would
leave town high and dry
only to become a hired gun for your
bitter rival it's tough
but for the most part you learn to move
on you find a new girlfriend a new job
even a new quarterback
but some betrayals are impossible to
forget
like when fredo sold michael out
i know it was you fredo
you broke my heart
or like when our president sold out the
country to mexican cartels
right now joe biden is having his fredo
moment at the southern border we told
you about it last week
i'm not saying joe biden's actively
colluding with the cartels
but just look at his policies and who
benefits and as always follow the money
because it certainly seems like both the
cartels and the democratic party are
mutually benefiting from what's
unfolding along the border i'm never one
to pass up a chance to say i was right
but here we are
we have real reporting now that joe
biden's administration is actually
coordinating with the cartels this is no
conspiracy this is a human smuggling
operation
solo illegal alien miners literal babies
are being dropped over the border fence
like sacks of dirt
left to waste away in the burning texas
sun hungry thirsty and crying out for
help but biden won't protect him instead
he chooses to work with people like this
he's gonna pull the door
stay right there before we move
okay
calm down
[Applause]
back up get your foot back get your foot
back in there get your heart back in
there ma'am man we're going to have to
taser you're not going to understand
what you're telling me
that wasn't a demon signaling the end
times although i wouldn't judge you for
thinking that no that was a member of
the flesh trade a human smuggler just
cashing in
biden has effectively partnered with
cartel coyotes like that screaming demon
border patrol has been forced to make a
deal with the devil they're left having
to work with the coyotes to coordinate
drop-offs drop-offs of insane people
like this guy
[Music]
is he possessed is he tweaking out we
have no idea this is who border patrol
stuck with this is who america can end
up with so the only way they can ensure
the safety of the border crossers and
themselves is this way
the biden administration has decided it
must work with cartel coyotes according
to former cbp commissioner mark morgan
they wanted to avoid scenes like the
ones of children being dropped over
walls in remote areas it may be safer
but it also makes the cartel's job
easier and more lucrative the cartels
have taken control of our border and
we're negotiating with the hostage
takers
the border patrol won't let innocent
children die in the desert because
they're good moral people but the cartel
will
biden's new business partners are evil
there's the cinola cartel one of the
oldest and most established of the crime
syndicates once led by you know el chapo
they thrive on violence
using it to protect their exploding drug
trade
there's also the jalisco new generation
cartel the newest terror on the block
who hang their murdered victims and
rivals from bridges
to scare away any challengers
or then there's the gulf cartel and the
losadis each group more violent than the
next
and thanks to biden our border patrol
has been handcuffed
biden turned our border patrol into
crossing guards
look at how they're forced to spend
their day
so you guys are your shuttle service now
huh
really
what's that no one patrolling the border
we just show up and just start grabbing
people without fats really
how many like this a day over a thousand
over a thousand per day
so
just totally open
and right there just through that one
hole
half full
thumb down that way wow
sometimes they're waiting out there a
long time and they get tired of waiting
and start coming into town because i was
just sitting here and they came up to me
asking me for help and i'm like what do
you want me to do and they're like can
you call do people call in all the time
with groups coming up to people and
asking for help and stuff like that
migrants are given folders and signs
asking for help to illegally sneak into
our country don't worry though the signs
have a smiley face at the end so you
know it's only good people coming across
and once these migrants are here they're
given money by us and ferried across the
country in plains and buses landing in
your backyard
and the cost of being smuggled not cheap
so these illegals owe the cartel
thousands
they work off their debt like indentured
servants worse
muelling drugs doing drops prostitution
hard labor
are really tough jobs
the money
they get to keep is then sent back south
to their families who pay the cartels
more fees for more migrants coming north
who biden lets in and the trafficking
rages straight up the hemisphere
drugs cheap labor violence and suffering
making cartels billions
biden's their partner in crime
primetime is here to expose these
criminals and this alliance
but it's up to you to make your voices
heard to your congressman and your
senator because this is what real
collusion actually looks like hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else